welcome everyone uh good morning good
evening
good night or you know wherever you may
be in this world
it's uh interesting time and uh
definitely
my first time at ndc and
it's exciting it's also
it's also a little scary because it's a
first ndc talk is
uh virtual i've done a lot of in-person
talks
and so this should be an interesting
experience and look forward to doing
this
having said that welcome to this talk um
you all
about feature flags what they are
uh what they look like and use cases
then we will talk about i want to touch
on the differences between deployment
and release and
agreed did that in in the previous talk
you did a you know great job uh
you know talking about that and a lot of
other topics that i will not be talking
in this talk so there is a little bit of
intersection i feel like my talk is
leaning more on the feature flags and
some frameworks and other things like
that
so we will get into the meat
of the talk with discussions on
feature flag frameworks and services
that enable these frameworks
and then we'll talk about you know two
or three different types of feature
flags like you know what use cases we'd
use them in
toggles you'd have probably heard of a b
testing and canary releases
so we'll talk about those and then i
will
end with some technicians
these are basically going to be pros
cons
best practices and gotchas and this is
mostly from my experience using feature
flags
this is a very broad and high level talk
on all these concepts and frameworks
because we are covering a
broad we're trying to go across the
landscape of feature flags so
hopefully you know that's you you take
away
a good understanding of feature flags
and i will leave you with
resources to do deep depths
so before i go on
let's talk about just a little brief
introduction to me
i recently changed jobs i now work at
microsoft
i am a remote worker so i'm used to
doing presentations on not in a
conference format
before that i was a microsoft azure mvp
and i also
run the orlando.net user group and
the orlando code cap
best way to get in touch with me is
either my email
or twitter i'm very active on twitter
but not always necessarily tech
i'll talk about every everything under
the sun
and with that we'll jump into feature
flags
so what you're seeing on screen is a
definition of
something called feature toggles which
is also called feature flags so
you know you you have different names
for these
uh this is from the earliest this is the
earliest definition i could find
and this is from martin fowler most of
you probably know martin fowler
and he defines it as a power
powerful technique for allowing teams
to my system behavior without changing
codes i know
what gear was talking about in his uh
previous
uh talk is testing and production so you
can do some others
in here using feature flags so
a flag is a
software it's it's something that is one
or more bits and it stores
binary values so it's a boolean true or
false
in the same context and software a
feature is a chunk of functionality
that delivers some kind of value to the
customer
thus a feature flag in the simplest
definition of
it is an if statement that surrounds a
chunk
of functionality in your software uh
feature flags in reality can be
and are more complex than an if
statements
but this this is a very good way to get
started
a feature flag is a way to
change your software's functionality uh
without changing or redeploying your
code so that is very important you don't
want to change
your code or you don't want to redeploy
it you simply want to hit a
data you know and everything happen
or you turn it off uh these are also
known as feature toggles and they
go by different names which we will try
to
discuss in this talk it's a set of
uh this is basically a set of patterns
software patterns which which can help a
team
to deliver new functionality to users
and it can do that
rapidly and safely
so just looking at this screen
this is a simple version of a feature
flag so if you
uh you know it has two different parts
the first
is a config settings and this config
settings in the app
app settings.json file and it has a
it has a second part that basically what
it's doing is it's uh
reading the config setting as you can
see it's reading the config settings
and then it's using that so this is
you know if you take away anything from
this talk this is a feature flag but
most of you have probably used
this at some level
so if you look at the anatomy of a
feature flag
it's uh what it is it's basically
uh has a bunch of components the first
one
is a toggle point so the toggle point is
the actual
point in the in the code where the check
occurs to see if the toggle is flipped
on and off or the feature flag is on or
off
in this case the if statement saying if
trial subscription is active
for user one this is a toggle point now
your code might
have multiple similar toggle points so
keep in mind that this particular type
of toggle point
uh can exist in multiple places for each
and then you have a toggle in this case
the
function that actually defines what this
code does
is a toggle router so for one router
you may have multiple points toggle
context so
that this starts to become a little
tricky what is the toggle context the
toggle context
is the happening behind the scenes
that actually the router takes into
account
while computing whether to toggle on or
off so in this particular case
let's say you want to check if a trial
subscription is active so what you're
going to do is
you're going to check the account
creation date and you're going to check
the number of trial days elapsed
or the number of 12 days remaining or
something like that so
that is the toggle context and that
happens
behind the scenes and finally
previous screen you saw the
appsettings.json file
with the config so that is the
toggle configuration so
uh some of the other things that could
uh exist in the toggle
configuration are things like let's say
you
your toggle uses a database you could
have the database connection string in
the toggle configuration so
it's very environment specific um
uh very environment specific uh like
values
it does not have anything to do with the
actual uh
context of the feature flag so those are
the four major points
and most of the feature flags you know
you come across
in the stock they'll have those at some
level
so let's talk about um deployments and
releases now these are
you know these terms are uh and the
reason i'm taking some time to
dive into this is because that's what a
feature flag does
it separates a deployment from a release
but today
if you go talk to most software teams
and
you know uh some are more mature than
others
but as a consultant when i go out into
the field i see that
teams often have difficulty
distinguishing between deployment and
release
so they use deployment and release often
interchangeably
which leads to a lot of confusion
now if you throw in the term ship
uh you know this is often used by
business facing entities like you know
project managers and program managers
and they use the term ship so this
complicates the situation even further
so
uh the ship if someone is using it
that's a more
uh i guess business facing term
but i also want to stress that
deployments and releases are different
and each one has a different risk
profile and that's what we're trying to
do is we're trying to
the entire the goal of this entire talk
is to
reduce risk like you don't
when you deploy something you don't want
everything to blow up that's what we're
trying to get to
so uh the term deployment when we're
talking about deployment
that's the process of installing
the new whichever code you code base you
have it's the process of
installing the new version of this code
on production environment so when we say
a new
version of the software is deployed
we mean it's running somewhere in your
production infrastructure
or environment deployment
does not necessarily mean that the
customers can
see the effects of this code so that is
the
deployments if we are able to deploy in
such a way
that after deployment customers that we
can choose whether the customers can
see or feel the effects of this new code
or not
we are reducing risk because if the code
doesn't work
we can go back fix it and
take care of that uh deployment should
have
minimal impacts on the customer
and they should be driven
by software teams so when that should
be controlled by the software team again
you know this is
very strong strongly worded opinions
but uh i think as the talk progresses
the reasons for these will i'm hoping
that the reasons for these will become
clearer
release so you saw that you know
deployment in the previous was
all all changes and you can see you know
it's kind of concentric circles so the
release are only the changes that are
visible to the customer so
i'm trying to say that you can deploy a
lot of your code
and you can make only a certain part of
it visible to the customer
so when we say a new feature is released
this means that production
traffic is hitting this co hitting the
code for this new feature
uh so releasing is the process
of pointing your production workflow
to point to the core related to the new
feature
so when production traffic hits the code
it takes on
all the risks associated with releases
you can have outages crashes uh
performance issues uh bugs
and maybe even you know it could be
completely wrong so all of these risks
are exposed to the customer the moment
you release it so the decision to
release new features
could involve various stakeholders and
these stakeholders
necessarily be software team members
they could be
a project manager they could be a
c-level xx
that is the difference that i'm trying
to stress is who is involved in a
deployment versus release
so depending on your team's practices
release can be considered as a rollout
of changes which means you can do
a roll roll back of a release
if necessary
uh i want to quickly touch on blue green
deployment
because this talk does not necessarily
go into it but i feel like this is a
useful concept to discuss anyway since
it involves
separating deployments from releases uh
blue green can be
used either by itself or with feature
flags
uh green is the new version of the
screen
as in fresh as the new version of the
code
is the currently current version of the
code that's running on
uh production so uh releases usually in
blue green involve pointing the uh
traffic from the from the current
version to the new version and this
is usually achieved
with the help of something like a load
balancer
and that's the most common way to do it
there are other ways to
obviously but i'm just talking about how
it's generally
done across the industry so
blue green is infrastructure level
changes
and the moment you point from blue
to green green takes on all the risks
associated with being in a production
environment now
if it's not working it's easy to roll
back so that's
one of the advantages of blue-green
deployments
uh since blue-green deployments involve
production infrastructure
this is a very useful technique to use
when infrastructure level change
so feature flags can still be used
in conjunction or separately so again it
all
uh it's all you know it depends on how
you want to
go about doing it and how you leverage
techniques and patterns
uh so uh keep some key takeaways uh
deployment should be continuous they
should have low impact
impact on customers uh releases should
be
a mindful business decision because they
could have high impact to the customer
hopefully positive
so in the next section i'll be talking
about the various feature flag
frameworks and services
and
the first one is something called
feature toggle
now this is the one that i used for the
last couple of years
uh so i wanted to touch on this uh it's
open source library
uh it's it was um
you know apache based open source uh
licensing so
uh you can simply install it into your
application.net application
with naked packages it supports multiple
dot net platforms so although i don't
know if suppose 3.1 yet
so that is one of the things that i want
to discuss in a later
slide is which one to select uh it
uses configuration files to configure
things like whether the toggle is on or
off
or whether you know if you're connecting
to
a different toggle toggling framework
like sql server
the connection string for that doesn't
config but
overall it gives you strongly typed
toggles in your c sharp code so that's
very important like
you don't want to have magic strings in
your quotes so
this alleviates that issue the other
thing is if
you know if there's something wrong with
the toggling like if the configuration
file is incorrect or missing
it will simply throw an
exception so the application will not
continue to run
in an unknown state so always watch for
exceptions when you're using these
feature flags
just something to keep in mind the
the feature toggle library it has a
flexible
provider model there there are some
predefined ones
but there's also um an interface that
you can implement
uh called i feature toggle that you can
use to customize
uh it supports a number of uh external
configurations so you can configure in
code itself uh which means you need to
redeploy it
but you can use app or web config or any
of those
configuration files so you can use
you can use sql sql server or ravendb
now
these are the ones that are currently
existing there
you can uh download the source code and
you can implement your own i'll
jump into that in a few minutes and the
reason i keep looking away is i want to
make sure i'm
staying on track so now
the downside of this is it has no
inbuilt telemetry
and the other downside of this is
i have not seen any uh new contributions
to the project in a couple of years so
it's a great one to get started with but
keep in mind that there's no new
contributions to the project
the next one i want to talk about is
feature management this is kind of
the new one new as in relatively new in
dot net core uh it's it's built on top
of the dot net
core r configuration system uh it's
it supports a local json file for
configuration
uh and you can toggle on and off using
the config file
but it and the it's extremely flexible
so um the other thing is it has
api extensions for asp.net core
mvc framework so you can do routings
filters
action attributes all of these you can
implement them with uh
using feature management feature
feature management flags have two parts
one is a name and the other is a feature
filter and
we'll look at code shortly to see what
this looks like
feature filters are basically scenarios
for enabling and disabling flags
for instance you could have a filter
that says only 10 percent of the
requests
have the flag enabled
azure ad configuration so you know first
two we talked about
feature toggle or
code based frameworks azure app
configuration
uh is a platform
as a service in azure uh it's used to
centrally
manage application settings so instead
of using
apps
in your code base you can actually store
app settings
in azure app configuration but you can
also use it to manage feature flags and
that is the
part i'll be focusing on in this talk uh
you can create an end-to-end uh
implementation of feature management in
asp.net core
using azure app configuration which
we'll be doing today
and the other thing is
the if you use it with feature
management
uh the it handles it has
code that you can write automatically
handle
uh looking at the updates without
redeploying an application
the uh by default the.net core
sdk pulls the changes every 30 seconds
or so if i'm not mistaken
so the advantages of using configuration
you can spin it up
within minutes it has
flexible key representations and
mappings for
app configurations and flags uh it has
tagging with labels which you can use to
set environment
type settings uh like if you want to do
one for test
one for cloud and you can use this
to do that it has a dedicated ui
um for feature flag management uh in
azure portal uh you can compare
different versions of flag
so let's say you keep toggling your flag
on or off you can
go back and see when it happened
and who did it and other things like
that
you can leverage azure manage
identity for securities that's that's
really important and
it also has encryption of sensitive data
at
rest and in transit uh
the other thing obviously it's azure
based it's very
infrastructure as code so you can use
arm templates or terraform to spin
up the service and manage it from azure
pipelines
and it obviously it has a sdks for
writing
for having code connected and the last
one i'll be talking about today
is launch directly which is a software
as a service so
azure app configuration is a platform as
a service
launched our case of software as a
service so there is a distinction
in that you don't have to spin up
instance of launch directly you create
an account and it's already there
so that's kind of the whole
concept of software as a service uh
it's a feature flag and toggle
management system it's very
it's a mature framework it's our service
it's been
and uh used for multiple years now
they handle you know
requests for flags per day
or so they claim uh it's uh
and they have various things like stream
architecture and cdns that make it
really fast and responsive
the thing i like about launch darkly is
that
you can it distinguishes clearly
distinguishes the testing and broad
environments
and you can even sync your flag so you
can turn on the flag and
test and when you have it ready you can
say i would like to copy this flag over
to prod which is really useful
and the user interface
for launch directly is very user
friendly
because they've been doing it for
multiple years now so a non-technical
user
then even a non-technical user can jump
in and handle
various things and launch directly so
uh some kind of so which one should i
use
there's going to be a question and my
answer as a consultant will be it
depends
so what you want to do is you want to
look at whether
if you have a green field solution or
not so if you have a greenfield.net core
solution
you want to go with feature management
and azure app configuration
if you have an existing app you can use
launch directly
if non-technical users are flipping
toggles
you can use if.net core is
what your system is in you can use
you know feature management or feature
toggles
and dotnet frameworks especially the
older versions you may want to use
feature
toggle because it has libraries for
older versions and
feature management seems to be more
forward-looking
uh for extreme customization uh feature
toggles actually
offers it it's really easy to customize
so
you know you can like if let's say you
wanted to use
cosmos db as your back end uh store
flag values you can easily customize
feature toggles to do that
the other one you can probably uh
customize feature management too i have
never tried it so
it's hard to recommend one thing i will
say
is feature toggle has been really useful
but
i'm not sure that it's being used
or being developed anymore because i've
not seen
active contributions in a couple of
years so
look at this matrix look at what your
needs are
and then make a decision based on that i
would not exclude it completely
but just be aware that it has no ongoing
support or contributions to it
uh we'll talk about some feature flag
use cases
and a quick time check so
that's okay i'm doing good on time so uh
so what i'm gonna do is i will talk
about each scenario
uh so the first one is uh toggles and
kill switches we'll do that with a demo
and so will
a b testing and canary releases um
these the examples i'm showing are kind
of
uh trying to build from ground up
and assuming i have time to do that
because i also want to
um talk about the technical
considerations
so maybe what we will do is uh you know
i'll do the first one and as maybe
if we run out of time i'll try to
look at some pre-existing code that i
created and we can walk through that
and i'll keep tabs sometimes so we can
do that so the first one is a
feature toggle a kill switch we talked
about this in simplest terms it's
on off button uh you can
turn a feature on or off uh by read and
redirect
code flow in production uh well
wrapped feature means you can easily
turn it off if it's
performing uh badly uh this can
you know this can kind of be the
difference between someone yelling at
you
or a public relations disaster minimal
impact
and how easily you can turn it off
determines that
then you can even combine it with
percentage percentage
rollouts and other things which i'll
show and a b testing
if you're doing this right you can you
basically take risk off the table
so having said that i
will jump into i'll do a couple of
things
i'll set up my development environment
and
i will start creating so
writing some code
okay so what we're going to do is uh
we will first start with a
for feature toggles we are going to
try to
for feature toggles we are going to try
to use
like a we're going to create a toggle on
or off but i'll also walk you through
the feature toggle library
in
visual studio so what i'm going to do is
i will create an mvc project
in visual studio make sure select
c-sharp because i don't
i'm not good at vb and what i'll do is
i'll call this
feature toggle and
uh dotnet framework 4.7.2
is good with me so i will create this
and i don't want https for now since
we're just
doing some demos so i'll create an
application
now i'm using visual studio because i
want to
kind of use feature toggles to not only
get you introduced
to this concept but also show how to
handle
all the applications
so while this is spinning
uh what we'll do is while this is
spinning we'll start talking about some
of the considerations
there it is let's continue with this um
so here is my visual studio project
and as you can see it's just a plain
visual studio project nothing special to
it
and what i'm going to do is uh
i will open up the home controller so
it's just quick and uh quick coding so
nothing's
i i'm not trying to do anything fancy
here i'll increase the size of this
fonts
so we can look at it and i will
start doing a couple of things what i'm
going to do is this is a very contrived
example
so in the index page
i will have
a section so let's say that
uh you know i have a section in here
that contains some
uh new feature so i'm gonna show this
new feature i'm gonna turn it on and off
with feature flags
so i'll show you how easy it is to do
this
with feature flags so the first thing
we'll do
is uh we will
put this we're going to turn this on and
off
on demand so i'll put this in a uh
statement and what i'll say is okay so
if viewbag.flag
is true then show this if not so
if i come into my
index controller if i do view bag
dot let's say i do a
flag and i set it to false
and when i run this
you will it should hypothetically
or you know if it's the code is working
of course so some of the dangers of life
coding
so ideally if the code is working this
should not show up so let's do this
and
so this is how you kind of start right
uh you know start off writing feature
flags you probably been doing it for a
bunch of years so
what i'm trying to show is how you can
build on top of it so you know
when you start with writing c sharp code
and
uh using that to toggle flags on or off
so you can you cannot see the new
feature it should have shown up on the
top so
uh so you know
in the days of your uh you know
back in the early.net days we didn't
have we didn't have any such fancy
concepts so we
simply used to change it and code and so
that required a
re uh recompile redeploy which was
which was painful so again
get away from these so you know with
when it's true you can see
you can kind of see the new feature at
the top so
there is the new feature right here
so okay so now you're gonna ask okay so
what's the
what's so special about this actually
nothing and
that's what i'm trying to show so what
i'm gonna do
is next uh i will say
you know let's see i assume this is the
ai feature
so in the web.config i'm gonna say show
a
true and in my
code i'm gonna come in and say
you know
instead of hard coding my uh
value i'm pulling it from the config
file so again you know people have done
this
and this requires a
re uh obviously the first time you do it
it requires a redeploy so
let's see when this finishes loading
you will see that it's showing the new
feature now let's say
you know the new feature is acting up in
production and i want to turn it off so
i come in here and i set this to false
i shouldn't have run on debug mode so
let's do this let's run on
non-debug mode
and when this finishes running you will
see
that the new feature is no longer
showing up at the top so
again this starts to give you you
already start to see
like let's do this so let's uh go ahead
and set this to true
and now when i come in and refresh this
page
my new feature shows up at the top so
it's already giving you an easy way to
kind of
uh change your feature in production
without having to
do an entire redeploy all you're doing
is editing
file but not satisfied with that so what
i want to do is i want to
and the other other problem with this is
let's look at my code so in my code
i'm having to go in and i'm having to
configure a magic string so a magic
string again you know
uh obviously if this ever goes through
code review
and someone ever you know
is even remotely
familiar with magic strings they're
going to reject it so
it's it's a lot of trouble and the other
problem we have with magic string is
let's say you have a show ai button
now uh you know i could easily mistype
this i could put a zero instead of an
n i could i could or that could be
i could make a typo and this typo would
actually
read from the web config into a
from a different variable that's kind of
similarly named but equal to the typo so
all of those become really hard to debug
so what i want to do is
i want to see if i can strongly type
this
so uh instead what i'll do is
i want to strongly type this so i will
come in here
and i will add negative packages so
my package is going to be called a
feature toggle so feature toggle by
jason
roberts that's the nuget package that
we'll be
using oh by the way um if we have
if we run out of time and i'm not able
to
walk through each one in
i will put this link up and my
github has all the sample codes for all
three scenarios
and it also has my presentation as
slides so
uh everything is on online so you don't
have to
you know worry about taking notes or
anything like that so let's
do this actually instead of doing this
i'm going to i realize that my time is
coming up so
i will jump in and i'm going to open up
the pre-existing code
so excuse me while this loads up i have
a machine with that to
32 giga but obviously it decides to run
slow when it's
doing a double uh
feature talk then you see i pulled up
the wrong one
so what i'm going to do is uh i'll go
through the existing code samples so it
makes it
makes for a faster experience and
we can kind of talk about details if you
want after this start
so in this example and
if you look at the new get packages i
use the nuget packages by
a feature toggle by jason roberts and
it's a feature toggle by jason roberts
it also installs this feature toggle
like
dot common which has a bunch of uh
it's built in dotnet standard for
compatibility with various.net
frameworks
so the way feature toggle works is
uh first of all you have to define
uh you have to define a class that
inherits from a feature toggle so the
first one is i'm using a simple feature
toggle
this is one that's that goes on and off
and i'm calling it ai simple feature
toggle
the one thing that you have to do once
you
have a feature toggle is you have to
specify a value for that you have to
specify a value for that using this
web config so in here what i'm saying is
ai
simple.feature toggle and i'm
configuring it to
toggle from the config file and the
value
is true and so
fit in
feature toggle and then in my code
and this is the part i was talking about
is the toggle point so
my toggle point simply checks if the
feature is enabled so that's
the that's the amount of code i'm
writing for this
and if that is true then that i'll
simply pass that
in here and this should go and it should
either show or hide the feature
i'm gonna do is uh something called
enable
on or after date feature toggle so this
this is where it starts to become
powerful so let's
say you have a feature that you want to
you know after june
15th so uh
you also have uh different options for
this so there's
enable before on or before date feature
toggle
and there's enable between dates feature
toggles so
let's say you're running a thanksgiving
sale like we have
in the u.s you could use enable between
date feature toggle so all of those are
available
with the feature toggle library so in
this case
i would add i would inherit a class that
uses ai date feature
and then in my web config what i'm
telling is ai.date feature
if it's on or after 11 july 2020
it will be enabled so when i do my
check so then obviously i come in here
and i
instantiate it and then when i do a
check uh it does the the feature enable
check
will be set to true now if i come in
here and set this to 15
it will be set to false so that it's
already starting to
you can already see how you know
i would set the date to 12 and
or at 11 59 pm or something and after 11
it will get it will simply kill the
feature
um so the other thing i was talking
about as feature toggles
have a really uh easily uh
you know they can be easily extended so
in this case what i'm doing is i'm
creating a custom feature toggle
which by inheriting it from the eye
feature toggle
and when i create a custom feature
toggle
i can simply implement whatever whatever
implementation i want to do
in here so let's say instead of pulling
this value from
here uh i i want to do like a highly
specific business logic i simply i can
write code in here that will do that
specific business logic or you know if i
want to
have a feature toggle that looks up a
store like
cosmos db which is currently not
supported by feature
this feature toggle library i can
implement all of that in here so
again once you implement it you go back
to
your code you use that to inherit
and you know this is where the strong
strongly typing part comes in
there is you can see that the part where
i pull in from the config manager that's
a magic string but the rest of the code
has
no magic strings so this is uh
feature toggle uh as
the the library the next one i want to
talk about is
uh let's go back to my slides
i'm gonna do a b testing uh demo with uh
feature management and azure app
configuration so
uh what i'll do is i'll jump back to my
screen so this
is azure app configuration so i can
simply go
to my azure portal and
i can look for app
so i'll say app config and
it will pull up an app config when i
when i go to create this
obviously i have to specify a resource
group
and then i can specify uh the name
of the app configuration store and
that's all i need to create it
now i'll go to preview previously
created
so we don't have to sit around and
waited spin
uh the couple of things you want to be
familiar with the azure app
configuration vendor
is access keys so these access keys
uh will actually give you things like
uh credentials to connect so in this
case i'll be using a connection string
from here uh the other thing is
the app configuration part you can you
can select
you can add a app configuration similar
to the one you use in your application
the advantage of doing it from azure app
config is you can actually connect it to
as your keyword and that way no one is
ever ha like let's say you have like an
api key or something and you don't want
anyone
else to see that api key you add it to
azure
app configuration as your key vault and
then you configure it from here but
again you know azure app configuration
is kind of beyond the scope of the stock
but we will talk about
uh creating uh features so what i'm
going to do
in here is i will add a beta flag
and as you can see it can be turned on
or
off so it instantly creates a beta flag
and it's off now let's go to my code
and this is my code so
what i'm going to do is i'll make sure
that we
can see it in here
uh so this is my project for uh feature
management
um and i need to do a few things so the
first thing
i do for future management is uh
obviously added that flag uh the next
thing was
uh i use something called dotnet secrets
so it's looks something
config and i copy pasted
the act the connection string from my
portal
i copy pasted the connection string from
my portal in here
and it's already set so
i'll do it right now
so that's that's the first thing i did
the next thing is if you look at my uh
project you will see that i added a
couple of
packages i added the microsoft azure
app configuration asp.net core package
since this is
asp.net mvc prime has been a core mvc
project
and then i added a feature management
dot asp.net core so i need these two
libraries
to talk back and forth with the service
and in the previous one where i did
that.net
user secrets that's the one that
actually
uh creates the connection string
that talks to this service
so uh
in the program.cs
uh i'll
read the configuration file so obviously
i need the configuration file
the next thing i did was actually
overloaded the options and i set it to
refresh often because
if you i think by default it's 30
seconds and
so if you're doing a demo it makes it
easier if you're not if you're not doing
it for 30 seconds
um and uh
enable feature flags and then finally i
connected it to the azure app
configuration
service let's see
obviously you need some of these
libraries on here
and the startup
in the startup i added the feature
management service
so what this is doing is
it's uh then
remember the part where i added the
asp.net core uh
feature management library for
asp.net core so uh that library can
actually be used to
show and hide actual controllers so i'm
doing a feature gate in here
and it's using my uh beta flag
so it's you
when the application starts up it will
use the connection string to connect to
azure app config
and then uh it is because i enabled
feature
i enable feature management the feature
management uh
service is now running in the back in
the middleware so
when it goes and hits up the asp.net
core
the controllers it actually if you add
an attribute
called feature gate you can actually get
it with the beta flag so
let's do this i will go to this project
so cd feature flags
see resources
and i'll do a dotnet build in here
so i have about 10 minutes remaining so
i'll be fast
dotnet run
this one actually goes to localhost
and i think it's localhost 5000 so
you will see that there's no uh this
the data controller is not showing up in
my
top uh library so what i'm gonna
do is i'll go to my feed
my flag feature manager and
azure app configuration and i will turn
this
on and when i turn this on
it takes a second but so i'll go and
refresh this in a second and hopefully
the demo guards are not against me
but in the meanwhile i'll
do is i'll prep the next one
there it is so you see the new uh beta
controller that was previously hidden uh
it just
showed up right here so this one
so that is
and again you know you can do all of
this by writing code
but by using feature flags you're kind
of leveraging the power of the platform
to
show and hide features so you can use
this for a b testing the next is
canadian releases so
speaking of canary releases i quickly
want to talk about
what canary releases so
um so canadian release is basically
uh very similar to everything we've seen
so far
but uh what we're doing is it's you know
it's the story of a canary in a coal
mine
so uh the canaries uh in
the previous days they uh when they used
to mine in various places they used to
take a canary
in and because you don't see uh
like poisonous gases but okay when a
canary stopped singing they knew that
something was wrong and they got the
heck out so similar to this what you do
is you
deploy a small section of code we call
it a canary
and you only expose it to a small
section of users or and when something
is wrong
you know because you're using metrics
you know that
there's something wrong so at that point
you can do a roll back
so uh so there's various ways of doing
this microsoft actually uses
leverages this in a concept called ring
releases which i believe a couple of
people before me have talked about
uh so as new releases new releases are
deployed to small number of users and
then it slowly expanded to a larger
section
so the migrate phase could
last for weeks and because you're
phasing it out
if you have any issues you can fix them
in the smaller
group and then as it rolls out to the
larger group they have
better versions and it's also very easy
to roll back
the one downside is you have to maintain
multiple versions of this
so that's something to be mindful about
and um for canadian releases what i'm
doing is i'm using some
a third-party tool called launch
darkly so you go to launch directly you
sign up
and you immediately get access to
feature flags
in this case i created a test flag it's
a simple
toggle on or off so you can say
you can already see that i did not have
to
go in and create a service for launch
directly
it's already there i just sign in and i
can
start turning my feature flags on and
off uh
so a couple of things i want to talk
about is
you the concept of users so in the
canary release
scenario i was talking about how you can
pick and choose
uh what users you want to release it to
so that's
also called targeting so you can
target a certain section of groups of
users
and launch directly it's called segments
so i have two segments
gmail users and the second segment is
called
yahoo users so uh
so the way this works is because i have
have two sections of users i can go back
to my
let's see
i can go back to my uh flag and i can
say that
uh the users who belong to gmail users
uh
for them the feature flag is certainly
true the for the users
that belong to yahoo users it's set to
false now
uh you don't have to be satisfied with
true or fall
for a percentage of users or let's say
percent of them can see it or even 10
percent
can see it so for instance in a real
production environment
this would be uh like you know this
would be beta users but i also want to
release it to
a bunch of live users but i only want to
do a small
section so there's something wrong i can
turn the feature flag off and completely
stop the targeting
so this is a really powerful concept
where you can control how your features
that are
already deployed are exposed to the end
users
and uh the launch durkley sdk
makes it really easy so
you get you you can you have like two
different
uh scenarios in here you have test and
you have prod and you can actually copy
a
feature flag or sync it between test
and prod so it's a really powerful
interface
um azure app config is getting there
so to use launch directly whether it's
desktop rod you go in and get the sdk
and
for code i already have code in here
so what i'm doing is i have launch
directly
so
for launch directly uh what i'm doing is
uh my
startup i'm actually adding a singleton
uh now this is simply for solely for the
purpose of this program but you can do
it a number of different ways
uh i added the launch directly sdk key
to my secret so i'm adding the singleton
so i can read it from the configuration
file
within the program i added the launch
directly naked package to the program
and uh so i instantiate
uh create a singleton for the
configuration
which is injected in here and what i'm
doing is
using the key i'm launching a launch
darkly client
now the launch startling client actually
has
this method default user
so let's do this
so the launch directly client actually
instantiates a user based on whatever i
feed into the
uh urls it's using the request.query
string to create a
user and those would be from the pre
configured users that you saw the users
the segments and the in the portal
are launched so what it's doing is it's
using this user
uh and it's talking to the test flag uh
and it's supplying the user and this
will
uh and the default is false so if it
doesn't match
any of this or if it's even an anonymous
user
it'll return a false but
if it has a match and the flag is turned
on for this user it will return it true
and then it'll show something in my uh
in my so if i go to my view
uh i i've hidden a simple uh
tag in here but a useful way to do this
is
uh you actually put features within here
and i realize i'm kind of almost at time
so i'll quickly run this and then
we'll jump into the end so
alan is that okay
what sorry you got cut off a bit uh
can i uh use a few more minutes to of
course i'm here just uh just use a few
more minutes no problem
okay
so what i'm going to do is i'll do a
dotnet build
in here for launch directly my
launch.live
and then i should be able to go
over and kind of start playing around
with my project
but there it is so now this
um so launch.mvc you can see the beta
tag and
that's because uh you can see that
the default user i supplied
has the flag turned on so let's go in
here so let's look at these users
so i'm targeting my users have the flag
turned on by default so what i'm going
to do
is i will go back and i will supply
a yahoo user so i will say
email equals i
yahoo user
so for this user it's turned on so
again uh you can see that as i start to
go through my yahoo
i users have added some exception in
here but
um sorry
okay so i explicitly excluded the yahoo
users so
it's turned off so you can see that i
want
to target um
users based on uh
certain criteria now you can decide what
you want this criteria to be so i could
have like
you know beta users uh that have
access to beta features and regular
users who do not have access to beta
features
and even in the regular users like i
said you can
roll out the beta features slowly so
and you can have multiple rings so this
these don't have to be the only two you
can add multiple segments
and you can bring them on slowly so i'll
finish
with a list of technological
consideration
so the first one is feature flags are
technical depth so please
uh you know maintain good
development practices on feature flags
remove the old ones
if a feature has been fully released
remove the feature flag
if it's a permanent flag then you have
to keep maintaining it
but don't do not daisy chain feature
flags so you know
don't take 10 feature flags and add them
in sequence
uh it gets really ugly there's an old uh
microsoft story
uh from in i think 2013 that they did a
tfs release and flipped on all the
feature flags at once and they brought
down the service so
uh be very careful or use the devops
principles
of small batches limit the number of
feature flags you're enabling and
disabling at the same time
the other thing is measure everything
launch directly azure app configuration
all of these
is actually slightly better at the
metrics part azure
configuration is getting there so uh you
know you have
metrics which means you get numerical
values you have logs which are recorded
events so use
these two and leverage them to make sure
that your
feature is performing as expected
and also the number of users that are
using the features
feature and you want to see their new
users are even using the feature at
all you know sometimes they don't so use
metrics to do all of that
uh and you know i discussed a couple of
frameworks and services
you can extend these so you don't have
to use these
if you have a different third party that
you like you can use
that but make sure you're not writing
your own
uh framework because you know feature
flags are intended to solve business
problems
actually uh help the release of business
problems they do not
solve a business problem on their own so
focus on
solving the business problem and then
encapsulate their releases with future
flags
do not write your own feature flag
framework
so i have uh as my time as consultant
had to deal with
cad boards or the change advisory boards
are these are really bureaucratic and
they
actually require you to get approval
from them for every
single or deployment or release so this
is what
you know they are really confused
between what a deployment is versus what
are releases so
what i would say is you know start
writing small sections of your code
deploy them but do not put them in the
production path
and you can when others
do their deployments and releases your
code simply gets deployed
and in the final step add a feature flag
and turn it on and submit it to the cab
code
this technique has worked beautifully
for me across
various agencies and hopefully it helps
you at some point
uh and the final point i want to talk
about is this is a quote from
the book accelerate by nicole forsgren
and jess humble
it talks about the fact that you do not
want to use long lived branches so
you know write small sections of code
merge them in
deploy them and finally use a feature
flag to release
use your feature flag as a
uh as the branch do not like have a
separate
feature branch that goes on for three
months uh
here's the small principles of
deployment and keep
deploying it and then your
feature flag becomes an execution branch
so in
production your execution branch is a
feature flag
you simply turn it on or off and
what i will do is i will actu so
these are the things that i thought that
we had discussed and hopefully i was
able to cover those
call to action you know please use
feature flags
if you would like to please contact me
with you know what framework you use or
which service you want to use
um i would be really interested in
knowing
uh this is my contact info if you want
to screenshot it or you can simply
search for me
i think my name is unique to where
people have not squatted on it yet
and uh these are some of the resources
um i will uh in the
uh slack i will add the
actual uh code i'll add the link to my
slides and stuff so with that uh thank
you very much
and i will uh and not uh
stop like i'll stop this
presentation
and then i will log into slack and see
how to if there are any questions i need
to answer
um